this is a production of Cornell
University
so so it's great to be here and
beautiful Ataka it's my first time at
the cornell so I'm very impressed and
I'd like to tell you about the research
that you know I started in my lab in
Vienna and now I am continuing at the
sock which is essentially revolving
around the question why do roots grow
and how do they decide to stop to grow
or continue to grow and the reason why I
think it's very interesting and
important to study roots is because why
are we typically every day we see the
shoots of fans and we think they are so
important to you know fix co2 and and
make air with the help of sunlight into
into matter into biomaterials you know
without roots they can't do this right
so roots they mined the soil they take
up the water they need to search for
water and nutrients and provide that to
the chute and so they are a huge part
determining plant productivity and
interestingly enough chute root
architecture is very as dramatic or even
more dramatic if you compare them to
shoot architecture that we see every day
so this is a beautiful drawing from
Weaver on prairie plants and you can see
that actually there is that that there
really it's easy to this thing where
species according to their root system
architecture you have species that
basically grow very deep and you have
species that form very shell root
systems that explore the upper so
there's much much better and and a big
question is what what actually
determines these differences and and not
only are these differences visible
between different species they are also
visible within one species and and so so
the work that I will tell you about
today is done in this tiny model species
are obsessed Aliannah and we use this
because there are so many tools
available for this but we can study the
processes that matter in the in the in
the larger picture of evolution also
within this single species
because different strains of these
species display very different route
phenotypes so so so we have natural
variation already within the first two
weeks of root development that you can
see here just seedlings of five
different strains accessions we call
them grown on agar plates and you can
see that there are accessions that grow
very slowly and accessions that grow
much faster accessions that grow that
put out way more lateral roots and
accessions that put put out less lateral
roots and and and using like this model
species net natural variation within it
we can actually try to identify the
genes and the variants of those genes
that actually determine those
differences and that will tell us how
actually roots you know grow are
basically genetically programmed to grow
or to in a certain direction to a
certain depth or stop to grow in
response to certain signals so I was
just alluding to the signals that make
roots grow or stop to grow this can be
nicely seen here also you know just a
five day very early time course is
enough to 2z that's very very very very
very clearly
so this those this is the same accession
because Arab topsis is a cell for those
are all isogenic plant which so we are
seeing here responses of the same genome
two different growth conditions where we
either remove the iron from the medium
or the phosphor or the sulfur or we
reduce the pH and you can see that the
same genome actually responds very
stereotypically to those environmental
changes for instance in iron deficiency
this accession stops to grow very early
on and then there's some hypo quartile
elongation even and then under and the
phosphate deficiency the same accessions
actually grows basically a little bit
faster than under full medium so so we
can see that we can study both the
genotypic you know a Kinsella tea for
different group or for root growth but
as well look at the responses of
genotypes and enough
sessions two and two to map the genes
and and identify the mechanisms that are
responsible to this and maybe even to
learn how this relates to adaptation we
make use of a resource that has been
built by air adopters researchers over
many decades starting in the studies of
the of the last century when people
started to collect Arab doctors all over
the world so this is a supporter
projection of the mainly the Northern
Hemisphere and every dot here
corresponds to one strain of every
DOCSIS that has been collected at some
point in time and you can see that
actually actually every DOCSIS grows is
a weed that grows kind of everywhere
goes from northern Sweden to southern
Spain even northern Africa grows from
the Atlantic coast into a central asia
and we know that there are even chinese
accessions so basically every doctor's
has expanded like all over Eurasia and
was introduced later on to to the
Americas and so so so all these strains
are available in stock centers we know
where they came from and many of these
strains have been a genotype with
high-resolution snip chips or even
resequenced completely so we can
actually start to draw the genotype to
phenotype maps and we can ask you know
are some some alleles actually
distributed in a manner that we can
understand how that relates to
adaptation so how do we do this we use a
method called genomes genome-wide
Association mapping I just briefly
outline how this works the principle is
very simple the statistics behind it a
little more complicated but it's not
necessary to understand this in detail
right now but the principle is we
measure a lot of phenotype let's say in
short route like the length of the route
we quantify this accurately we take the
genome sequence or the genotype data and
then we try to correlate the difference
of the variation in the route lengths
between different exceptions to the
variation in the genome sequence so we
do this all over the five chromosomes of
Arabidopsis and and basically for every
polymorphism that
fine we can ask do accessions that have
a long road have a different nucleotide
at that position then accessions as
compared to accessions to the short
route right if all the accessions that
long would have an a at this position in
all of the accessions with a short would
have a G this will be a very high
correlation very high association and
then we can basically plot the
probability for this association are
like over the whole genome and we were
looking for Peaks where this probability
is so it's a it's a leg of the negative
logarithm of the p-value is very high so
that's essentially the plots you will
see today so when I started my lab six
years ago it was actually very simple
this part was actually getting very
simple because there were lots of labs
who loved to sequence ever drops of
strains so you know the labs of Detlef
Vigo Magnus North Bergen Joe Ecker
they you know started sequencing more
than a thousand extensions and
genotyping efforts have been on the way
so so we could just like download this
part so that problem was solved but was
not solved in the end the association
mapping problem was largely solved as
well by by efforts from Magnus North
Works and there was like lots of I mean
of course there's lots of activity in
human genetics to do the same thing and
so so the so the methods were actually
well outlined the problem actually is or
was the phenotype in so how to measure
thousands hundred thousands of roots
without making credit students jump out
of the window and pure you know because
it's like so horribly boring right and
so so what we developed was then like
multiple ways to actually measure
phenotypes as much as possible in an
automated way so so the main pipeline
and that is all the data that I'll talk
today is based on this so we grow 24
seedlings on a plate and then we image
them very efficiently using a scanner
cluster so we can acquire 300 plans
within
minutes and then we have written
algorithms that actually transform this
image and image like this into data
which is outlined here so this these are
virtual representations of those
seedlings and and because this is all
you know data we can we can basically
measure everything starting from the
root length to the to the angle at which
roots grow and to the shape of roots and
so on using this pipeline and and there
is no human intervention needed for this
step because those things work largely
automatically so with this pipeline we
we I think we we have quantified I think
almost like three million individual
images of seedlings and different
conditions from very different genotypes
and that works very very nicely for the
first couple of days for root
development to quantify accurately and
with very high at a very high scale
alight large scale phenotypes and then
we also but I won't talk about this
today we also automated confocal
microscopy that we could actually get
nice confocal images 3d stacks of images
where we can actually measure cell size
and and and things like meristem size to
determine what is the area in which
cells divide and we could also
successfully use this to map regulators
of cell size and meristem size and where
genetic variation is cause so for
differences of cell size and meristem
size ok so today I'm gonna talk about
two projects mainly one two and a half
where we that illustrate I think nicely
what we can do and what types of
questions we can understand using
natural variation in our tools and this
all basically got started with this
experiment where we used 200 around 250
accessions
and exposed them to different conditions
so we just grew them on agar plates like
depicted us here so those are is one
accession grown in three replicates
where I show three replicates for each
condition and you can see that as I
showed in the movie before that in
different
conditions when we drop our different
nutrients we actually get a very
different route response and so we did
this for each of those 200 around 250
accessions and we then can encode traits
and colors so here we encode growth rate
so a yellow color means that there's
high growth rate a blue color means a
low growth rate and each of those rows
here corresponds to one accession so
basically here you can see different
patterns of growth responses you can see
that there are conditions like iron
deficiency where you know most of the
accessions do basically the same thing
they start to grow some of them stop
earlier so the blue that already get
blue on day one some of them stop later
so basically continue to grow despite
this deprivation of iron but then there
are some conditions where basically some
accession spacing increase their growth
on day four for instance in some
accessions decrease their growth so you
can see this this response to the
environment is is really dependent on
the genotype and because especially
micronutrients like like iron will be in
sufficient quantity already in the seed
this is most likely not dependent on
like accessions running out of a
nutrient but rather an active response
to the information to somehow a sensing
process that tells them there's less or
there's basically less of this nutrient
around so you can see that in in this
nice movie where for iron deficiency you
can visualize very nicely this different
response so those are two exceptions
that that grow the same way under for in
the full medium but this accession grows
like busy stops that grows very early on
and then somehow prioritize the
hypertonic quarter grows a little bit
more in this succession continues to
grow to a later time point under this
right so we can use this to then
quantify this and then ask what is
actually what are the genetic variants
that are causing this difference so the
first you know project that we started
we started to phenotype 138 sweeter
success
34 Swedish accessions from this region
those have been collected by Magnus not
work and Sweden is actually very
interesting it is actually very
interesting collection because within
Sweden even if if you think a whole
Sweden is called there are differences
in climate and northern Sweden is way
colder than southern Sweden and there
are also differences in soil types and
so on plus it is a local population so
mostly the same alleles will will be
present in this in this population and
and and and it's it's easier to make map
comment variation for this at least
that's what we that's what we thought
and I think that's actually what we
found ok so just to demonstrate you so
when we did iron-like growth on iron
medium so you can find everything like
all almost always those natural
variation some of the exceptions they
actually stopped very early their growth
some of them stopped late and basically
elongated longer and then when we map
this we found this one peak on
chromosome 1 that was above our
significance threshold that was very
significant so when we then zoomed in so
we in this in this region it was in a
region the snip was in the region of pro
2 which is a major regulator of iron
homeostasis so so this is from from a
review where you can see the enzymatic
activity of Afro 2 where where it
basically does this catalyzes this
reaction from iron and to iron 2 plus
which then can be transported within
into the cell and that function has been
known already a long time and made it a
prime candidate to space on its
annotation so usually we don't like to
use annotation for prioritizing
candidate genes because there's always
the danger that you kind of wag your own
tail that you kind of think something
plays a role and then when you look at
the knockout mutant of course most
likely will play a role so we always
typically take additional independent
data to assign more confidence to Canada
magine before we go on a more
time-consuming you know genetic
characterization of this so in in terms
of this we actually looked at the
expression level of row two in those
different exceptions I don't show the
data here but 402 was in what basically
expression was increased in the
exceptions with a long route as opposed
to the ones for the short route so there
was additional evidence for this of
course the final test that you can do is
to take the alleles from those
exceptions and put them in the mutant
background if the mutant background
shows a phenotype and so so indeed fro
to actually under low iron conditions
that shows a shorter route and so what
we did is we took the allele the fro two
allele from this short rooted accession
we took the early from this long road
and accession in an intermediate
accession and we we put it back into the
mutant background and in order to
because it's a very tricky business
because we're dealing with expression
level differences because we don't want
to be susceptible to two random
insertion expression events you can
imagine that transgenes can insert in
different areas of the genome and that
might by chance
basically just confer a higher
expression level or lower expression
level because that can be position
dependent we we do a lot of T 1
independent insertions and a phenotype
in T 1 based on an honor on a
fluorescent marker system selection so
to be sure that we can actually average
out position specific insertion events
and then when we did this we actually
see that under iron deficiency the the
the route length was complemented much
much better so this is the the mutant
canola transformed with the empty vector
in in
transgenic lines that were complemented
with this long route fro to allele why
when we complemented with this short
route fro - ma allele it didn't
compliment at all and most likely
because fro - is in in those exceptions
not expressed at this at that point of
time okay so so that made us confident
to say actually variation natural
allelic variation for fro - is causal
for this and it's just another example
where we actually can go from the
phenotype to the gene with genome-wide
Association mapping very efficiently and
so so why is this so the polymorphisms
between those two alleles are non-coding
in nature so there is no change of the
of the of the amino acid sequence of the
protein there are a couple of changes in
the coding sequence that don't lead to
an amino acid change and there are also
some snips in the regulatory region so
this is all non-coding non-coding
regulatory and and consistently with
this when we measure in the lines that
actually complement a mentor to a better
extend the expression it is much higher
compared to the the short route allele
of row 2 and this is also completely non
surprisingly true for the enzymatic
activity so this higher RNA expression
of row two translates in a higher
activity of the enzyme that we can
measure in this in this essay so so we
can really like going from from the
genetic variation over the expression to
the enzyme activity we can make the case
that this is more cause is core so
another interesting thing was when we
thinking of natural variation that that
we see you know common natural variation
populations it will be most likely
related to adaptation but of course like
growing on agar plates in the first
couple of days and growing a little bit
longer it doesn't tell us so much about
effects that relate to fitness
so we basically did the test that we
grew these complemented lines under
alkyl
pH where iron availability is actually
reduced and we can see that the the
allele of the fro - from the lines with
the longer roots is actually much better
in in in in dealing with this then then
then the allele from the line of with
the shorter roots so we think that
somehow gives the plans and advantage to
grow in iron limited environments so
does it matter when we look at the when
we look at the places where the
accessions come from so this is a map of
sweden and this is the soil type that is
indicated by the colors and you see that
when we look at the - fro alleles one of
you is the a allele pictured in black
the other leaders the G allele pictured
in in in green we can see that most of
the the black allele is actually in the
north of Sweden where there are pots
oils which which is a specific type of
soil that's highly acidic and where Iran
for instance gets washed out very fast
while the other allele is predominantly
in the other soil types in the south so
so that could give an indication that
actually the different alleles might be
at a patient's to different soil types
now this is not not not a like complete
evidence because it is very different
difficult to separate population
structure so that means those guys are
way more related among each other than
those guys from from adaptive features
so to really test this we will need to
go to sweden and and to reciprocal
transplants and and we haven't we
haven't done this yet but it's a hint so
it's an hypothesis that this might
actually be one of the one pro to alia
might be an adaptation might be
beneficial in pot salt okay so that's
one of one of these these stories and
these projects will be identified one
gene and in variants of the gene that is
responsible for a certain trait and for
a certain response and we have a couple
of those in the lab and it's very very
interesting but of course but of course
kind of something that we know from you
know
genetics Balaji is that genes don't act
alone so you often have interacting
genes you have pathways you have multi
sub unique proteins and and the question
is can we actually using natural
variation and and and and and and and
and the variance from these to identify
more than one gene but but there are the
pathways or or modules of genes that
work together as proteins and and and
are important in for regulating traits
and biological functions and so so so
that is actually one of the one of the
most exciting applications of
genome-wide Association mapping that I
see because unlike a mutant screen where
you basically really try to isolate the
one mutation we are having to deal with
like a bunch of like of many mutations
that we have to consider this you can
see as a disadvantage it because it
makes things complicated but you can see
it also as an advantage because if you
you might think that in one like to
achieve one trait variation you might
target the same pathway multiple times
and if this is so it might be a very
important pathway for that trait okay I
wouldn't tell you about this if I
wouldn't believe in it so so this is why
I believe in it so what you first need
to do if you want to consider multiple
genes is you you need to map multiple
genes and so so the key and V was is
actually to increase the number of lines
you look at because it's a statistical
approach it's a numbers game so so what
we did here was we increase the number
of lines that we where we measured
growth rate up on iron deficiency from
the 134 that I showed you into typical
200-250 lines that we typically use to
almost 500 and you can see that there
are way more signals above the
significant threshold than previously so
we got more than twenty now we can
actually start to ask questions that are
other genes that are close and immediate
proximity of those Peaks possibly
interacting in the same pathway in the
same module and so to do this we we
leveraged a genome
Kayle gene model from a productions it's
called era net and that was basically
generated by in Sewickley and soory slap
at the Carnegie Institution a couple of
years ago and it integrated all like
massive data types that were available
at that time and those were like
expression datasets
Co expression from genes protein-protein
interaction datasets literature mining
and so on in a probabilistic network
model that essentially depicts the
probability of any two genes and the
average of the genome to interact
functionally and so so when we basically
ask then when they took this network and
asked if genes that were like in
immediate proximity of those Peaks were
predicted to have a functional
interaction we actually found quite some
of those evidences there and when I
first looked at this this this seemed to
be most interesting to me because it was
a leucine rich receptor kinase cluster
yes
for those four genes we don't really
know it's one of the one of the evidence
codes in in the error net but for these
genes it was actually coevolution the
evidence code so basically a fighter
genomics core that gave gave rise to
these potential interactions but but
yeah so so we are currently
investigating if these genes are always
or maybe in specific conditions are
co-expressed so yeah so so that was very
interesting to us because like the one
emerging paradigm in the field is that
actually many of those receptor kinases
that typically they I mean those those
are receptor kinases so they have a
receptor domain leucine-rich receptor
kinase domain leucine receptor now
leucine-rich repeat domain outside of
the cell and in the tardis that they
basically can detect ligands outside of
the cell and then activate the kinase to
signal something in the cell and that
and it has also thought that they
basically multiple lrrr Ches can
interact on the membrane and even
compete compete with each other to
prioritize you know growth or defense or
other processes so that there are keys
to basically receive signals and in a
combinatorial manner then lead to
signaling cascades that affect growth
and this is just one example of I think
the best studied system from Joanne
Corey's lab mainly where the the bride
one leucine-rich receptor like kinase
leucine-rich repeat receptor like kinase
interacts with others in computer and
and leads to a differential interaction
of ear but one with either this kinase
or this kinase right so there is so so
so the thought the paradigm is basically
now that but depending on the
interaction and the abundance of
receptors you might get a different
signaling output and that was the reason
why I thought this might be interesting
because
we have three receptor kinases here and
one protein kinase that are downstream
of receptor kinases and and that might
just be like the module interesting to
perceive the absence of iron and then
the two different cause responses okay
so of course very hypothetical right so
so the next step is of course because we
before we wanted to embark on a very
laborious journey to study this was to
see if we find any other evidence than
this Network evidence and the Seaworth
evidence whether those four genes might
actually interact and when we think of
the data that we already used for here
that's phenotypic data of accessions
with different alleles we we can
actually think we can reuse the data and
do a different test that is almost
independent of this one so in
genome-wide Association mapping we test
for variations like the genotypic
variation and phenotypic variation for
the correlation but we do it one snip at
a time right we don't consider multiple
snips together now when we think those
those genes and their variants might
interact we can actually look for
accessions that have certain
combinations of those multiple of those
four genes
and then see if certain combinations
respond very different non-additive if
you compare them to two to the other
combinations where you only have one and
that's what you can do with the same
data and that's what we did here so we
have four genes and we can have each
gene in a major or minor earlier
configuration if you want to simplify it
to two versions and so so we can have
exceptions that have either all of them
in the major earlier combination or you
can have exceptions that have all of the
four genes in a minor league
configuration and you can have
everything in-between
right and so so what is striking from
this image is that basically these
higher-order minor league combinations
all are fast growers so this is a growth
rate up on iron deficiency and so the
fastest growers are all exceptions that
contain three or four combien
of minor leaders of those four genes
with one exception that is the the
double combination for two specific
genes for one and SS three so so that
was to me at least it was enough to say
okay let's spend some time to test
whether this is true okay so I told
Santosh my post of just generate all
possible higher mutants and yeah I took
a while we get in a time machine three
years later we have this so so so so
this is basically the outcome of all
possible combinations of those mutants
so so we can see it's very complicated
there are a lot of effects this is the
growth rate up an iron deficiency and
and this is kind of the same
nomenclature as I showed you before with
the variants like four genes and the
capital letter is the wild type form and
then a non-capital letter is the mutant
form okay so let's go let's go directly
through the statistics here and I'm
gonna guide you through this complex
analysis okay so the first good news was
that and we knew that before we tested
the single mutants before but so so all
of the single mutants are significantly
different from from the wild-type so
this is a significant code for the ANOVA
and we can test the effect of singles
and of multiples okay so so we know that
all of these receptor like kinases so
those are those three and the protein
kinase are somehow necessary for the
appropriate response to iron deficiency
okay so that's good interestingly like
those those three actually grows much
slower than wild-type and this one grows
slightly faster okay so so then we we
start with their interactions because
that's our working hypothesis that those
four genes interact so the first one
actually is very striking the most
interesting and most significant
interaction actually occurs for those
two receptor like kindnesses sr 3 and
four one and you can see this very
nicely they really are aesthetically
interact because if you look at the
single mutants for those two genes
compared to the wild type they lead to a
strong reduction or
we'll go through it up on
iron-deficiency right if you combine
those two mutations you actually get
less less lesser decrease right so
basically we were typically you know in
the additive model we would assume that
we would get like a growth rate around
here but we actually get a growth rate
that is reversed right so it's a typical
it's a typical evidence for an epistatic
interaction so those jeans truly
genetically interact and if you remember
the variant analysis that I showed you
previously it's the same combination
that we actually show you that we
actually found this dramatic increase
already using the double the double in
the next sessions that actually covered
the double minor-league combination so
there's something special about this
interaction okay
so that's a very primitive model so this
is my leucine-rich repeat domain and
it's the kinase and so they - somehow
it's a working hypothesis interact
they're on the membrane they interact
and they somehow regulate growth upon
iron deficiency so the question is is it
is it actually true so some evidence
came actually interestingly at the time
where we were still busy generating the
double and the triple and quadruple
mutants came from the lab of Yusef Kadir
who is a colleague at who was a
colleague at the Gregor Mendel Institute
and he did in vitro screen for 80% of
all leucine receptor leucine-rich
receptor like kinases in the arab
lobsters genome in multiple hundreds and
he did an in vitro screen where he
expressed all of these and and scored
the interaction using using a color
assay and and one of the most noble
notable interactions was a man among the
two receptor kinases that we found that
were included in his in his essay so sf3
and for one so that gave additional
evidence that they might truly interact
physically on the membrane we could also
do when we did the KO IP to test this so
we
basically pull down first one receptor
kindness sf3 and then we pulled from
this pull down the other one with
another tag and and so we basically
could show that we can actually pull
them down together so that they are very
close by so so that would be another
evidence that they physically interact
and we're currently doing more advanced
microscopy to test us using using
advanced microscopy methods like Fred
okay so so we believe that those two
receptor kinase interact on the membrane
but how does this relate to iron to low
iron levels and growth response to low
iron levels so so when we treat reporter
constructs that we express in tobacco
with water we we basically still see a
high abundance of of these proteins that
are fused with fluorescent with the
fluorescent protein in here in in the in
the membrane but when we basically
withdraw the iron we see that actually
the signal gets much weaker we can
actually see this when we do the Western
blot in the cemetery we can see that if
we treat with an agent that removes the
iron we lose this protein right it gets
degraded so so one of the mechanisms
that that somehow plays a role here is
that if you have low iron levels the
receptor kinase will be removed from the
membrane so the interaction partner when
we did the same experiment as here we
didn't observe any depletion from the
membrane so so we think actually in the
context of this office of this receptor
kinase module we have the two receptors
that are interacting and then iron
deficiency leads to the removal of one
and and this other one might be free for
interaction with other partners on the
membrane of course we wanted to test if
this is really true in the root so those
who are just
tobacco SAS and because we can do long
term imaging we can actually do the same
experiments in growing roots and so so
that is one of our experiments where we
track the root over time
and on the same microscope we have a two
chamber system we basically add water to
this and we add further on to this it
removes the iron right and so the signal
that you observe here is again from this
one receptor kinase that we think is
degraded and you can see under normal
conditions the signal is quite constant
and the growth is quite constant of the
root but under iron deficient conditions
you can see two very interesting things
there's no growth and at the same time
the level of this receptor kinase is
much lower then somehow there is an
increase of the signal again so there's
more receptor kinase gets again in the
membrane and that is the point of time
when it starts growing again so
basically the abundance of this receptor
kinase correlates very well with growth
under iron deficient conditions we did
this experiment more than 12 times
repeated and we can see very
reproducibly that the signal off the
protein is kind of stays constant under
control conditions and basically
decreases much under ferrous iron iron
deficiency conditions and then increases
again at a point so so we think the the
transient essays that we the essays that
we did in tobacco are really well
representing that one of the effects of
the iron deficiency is to remove this
receptor kinase from the membrane okay
so let's get back to our power
experiment here so we can actually see
multiple other interaction terms and
essentially it tells us that there's
evidence from the genetics that all
these four genes interact based on the
mutant analysis so this leads to another
very non sophisticated model that that
basically all of them somehow interact
and that they impact growth okay so
that's not very satisfying so we were
very happy when we got another hint from
Yousefi dears lab because he had done
this in vitro screen of 80% of all the
receptor kinase leucine-rich repeat
receptor kinases and Abraxas and another
interaction that he found with fir which
is the ii kinase that we had found that
i showed you here
was that it interact with flagella and
receptor FLS - so this is a receptor
that that perceives flagellin from
bacteria and leads to the onset of the
defense response and so so that made us
to think that that maybe we found a
module that somehow connects defense and
iron deficiency signaling and so the
first thing that we did together with
yourself was to test the effect of
flagellin on the root growth of of the
mutant so so in the wild-type if you
apply for Jaylyn here you see a
reduction of root growth because the
root stops to grow but this is abolished
in the receptor mutant because there's
no receptor to perceive the flagellum
and it's also abolished in the FIR
mutant which is our one of our receptor
kinases you can can see this here so
somehow we have found though at least
one of these receptors that we found is
involved in the regulation of growth
upon iron deficiency but also upon the
presence of mayor of molecular
signatures of pathogens and this is also
true so the the Ross response is one of
the earliest defense response is also
impaired in this fur mutant all right so
so more evidence that there is a
connection between growth regulation and
a low iron conditions and under defense
situations and you can also see that the
if you look at the growth of bacteria
basically the firm you is almost as as
much compromised as the FLS to mutant
here so so we know then that one of the
components we found is involved
interestingly another receptor kinase of
the of the three we found si 3 and there
was also the one that I showed you
earlier with its interaction with but
with fur one has also been implicated in
immunity in a different study before
bye-bye Jane Parker where basically this
mutation of this and different alleles
lead to compromised immune response
so so this in leads to our current
working model that I want to share with
you where we actually have we have we
have stumbled upon this module here and
we know it is important for the
regulation of growth up on iron low iron
levels and we we know also that at least
like this this part you can interact
with the effortless 2 receptor and what
we actually think what's happening here
is that it's a module that processes
signals from bacteria or like signatures
from bacteria and iron abundance it like
in the same module on the membrane so
when when there's iron when there's iron
deficiency so typically those three are
in a complex under happy growth
conditions no irons or pathogens and so
under iron defer one is basically not
available for an interaction with FLS 2
but if the iron is going away and we
think this might be in part perceived by
this receptor kinase you remember the
mutant actually had increased growth
rate under iron deficiency as if it
wouldn't sense that the iron is low we
think we know that
saf3 is actually degraded and those two
receptor kinases don't interact directly
and fur is actually free to interact
with FLS 2 receptor which somehow needs
to stop off growth so that's a working
model and there are many open questions
which we currently solving by code
treating with iron and flagellum and and
so so to corroborate this working
hypothesis I mean what is known that
there's a there's a very intimate
relation of iron levels and defense that
has been described in a very descriptive
manner in the past by people and we
think that actually might be a key
module so I think what this this nicely
shows is that you you can't can leverage
you know quantitative genetic approaches
to identify multiple genes get to
interesting mechanisms that tell you not
interesting and novel biology and lead
to to basically a better understanding
how actually there's crosstalk and then
interesting thing about this crosstalk
is that it seems to be entirely
happening on the membrane okay so I'm
running out of time is that yeah okay a
few minutes okay so so there's the other
question so is this is this specific to
iron so when we stumbled about this we
were actually very we were kind of
surprised and and so so so we are
thinking okay so it's just one way
there's like this one intersection of of
the response to micronutrient
deficiencies or low levels in the
environment and defense but when we then
it's other screens and we do a lot of
screens we actually found something very
interesting in collaboration with heart
and we were share true is that the in
ROM Whomper here when we looked at zinc
deficiency response but you can see very
nicely that accessions also respond very
differently some accessions actually
don't bother very much even increase the
growth rate and the zinc deficiency in
the first couple of days and some of
them actually reduce the growth rate
quite a bit so we met this we found a
zinc deficiency specific peak on
chromosome 4 and that was located very
close to the ACI one gene and other azi
so ACI one gene is implicated in
systemic immunity in priming based on
the effect of it's a lake asset and that
already have been described and it's the
prime candidate in this region because
it's also expressed much higher up on
zinc deficiency than all the other genes
in this region so so when we then use
the mutant and the OVA expressor and
conducted those growth essays under zinc
deficiency conditions we actually see
that that these that the lack of a zi1
that is is an immunity gene actually
causes roots to grow very to respond
very differently to the zinc deficiency
so this seems to be specific to zinc and
and when we did the same essay with the
same Newton and over a special line
there was no difference under iron so
when we did the complementation we could
actually conclude a zi variation that
the a zi locus is is truly causal for
this different closed behavior under
zinc deficiency because if we took a
long route allele and transformed it a
long route a zi le transformed in the in
the knockout it was much better
complementing the short route phenotype
under - think so so then of course the
obvious obvious conclusion or the
hypothesis would be that there's an
interaction between a zelich acid and
and zinc deficiency because this is one
of the the a zi one gene is one of the
key genes is required for the response
off of the plans to this to this signal
immunity rarely signaling compound and
indeed it is so if we look under zinc
deficiency we can see that basically the
the reduction of root growth rate that
we observe in wild-type with the
application of aza is abolished in zinc
limited conditions and this abolishment
is largely dependent on a zi one so we
so we think there is a complicated ACI
one so is there like acid immune related
signals are dependent on the zinc status
of the plants and we even like thought
this is this is very interesting we
don't really know what this means
I mean we know that zinc and iron as
well are very very important for immune
responses and that there's in many
systems there is a kind of war for for
iron and also zinc is used for defense
responses whether this simple
interaction is is also conserved in
different plant species and so so we did
the experiment in rice because it was in
hand for a collaborator of Hatton and so
you can see that actually this root
inhibition of root development so when
we increase the concentration of aza
under normal conditions inks sufficient
we basically
inhibit the formation after root
completely right or the emergence of the
root and if we remove the zinc from the
medium we basically don't affect this
process at all right so so there so this
interaction of zinc levels and AZ and
acetic acid and in Abraxas depend on a
zi1 is it's truly somehow a process
that's relevant for for many species and
and the big question is why why is it
actually okay but that's a question that
I can answer right now I mean just other
than speculating okay so I just go to
the acknowledgments so I hope I've shown
you that you know the the way that we
approach this problem using natural
variation can tell us a lot on how roots
decide to grow or not to grow because it
depends on genes and genetic variants
how at which levels in which time
actually growth has stopped and
presumably defenses and in those two
cases are basically defense responses
are started and and this work was mainly
done by so the iron did work was done by
central sucked by a postdoc who started
a couple of years ago at the GM I now
came with me to sock which I'm very
happy about was assisted by a master
student very talented and the second
part of the story was also done by
Santos at bi and and most of the work
was actually done in Homs brochettes lab
at Enron Montpellier by Nadia Blanc and
with that I thank you for your attention
very much
you know what the mechanism
stop
yeah that's that's a that's a very
that's a very good question well we know
that the meristem basically they get
shorter cell division activity goes down
so there will be that there will be
signaling on the cell cycle by which
means we don't really know whether it's
like you know oxen dependent or or any
other signaling pathway we don't really
know but yeah once we have all this we
can actually test this using mutants
when you get up
a bunch of challenge
the intuition rather the promotion what
was the reason for that and can you say
anything about these enhanced
yeah so that's a that's a very good
question so we also pursued the growth
control and and phosphate but with the
iron
we were just faster so with the foster
we haven't quite figured out we didn't
find for instance so so we okay so we
didn't increase the number of accessions
to have better mapping ability and
phosphate because we were the postdoc
who was working on the iron was faster
doing this so it's not it's not
intentional design but rather the way
how it is historically developed with
bits faucet so it's a one thing that I'm
currently doing at Salk is that we will
with it be overcoming some bottlenecks
for those studies so the major
bottleneck is actually pipetting hands
right now
to put the seeds on plates and so i'm
building right now robot and we will do
basically all these conditions with a
thousand accessions and we'll have much
better mapping ability and then can
really in enforceable conditions also
consider this multi gene approach so so
yeah so i probably in five years i can
answer your question
the physiologist to be more
now with growing pains
and hydroponics
growing plants or Niagara's especially
when I've got terribly convenient
so one of my first questions
tested
relationships under
such that you verify there were one
number two
for longer periods
those witches
yeah yes so so that is a very valid
concerns concern so so first of all we
are most interested in the signaling
aspect in this kind of decision-making
aspect so so so we think actually
growing them very early already tells us
something about this now if we're
thinking about everything that relates
to adaptation I think it's very very
important to consider soil and later
because phenotypes and another project
that I didn't talk about where we looked
at more at at the angle at which roots
grow and we found a very interesting
gene and exercise gene that that
actually affects how our oxygen is
transported we did the experiment that
we basically cut the extreme accessions
that we knew were very different in
their early growth behavior in very
large soil parts and then we did
excavation and indeed those accessions
were very different in terms of their
rooting depth so in that in for in that
for that question
it it seems that there was a very almost
linear relationship between those early
growth rates that we measured and the
rooting depth now that is not not
necessarily true for other conditions
for instance if we think about those
nutrient deficiencies of course at some
point you know plants will run out of
the nutrients and then they I mean they
don't have enough to grow right so so so
that would be anyway like the the
question of nutrient deficiency and
homeostasis is a very different question
from the dawn of the one that we are
asking right now but it would be good
yeah I mean like for questions that that
that that are related to adaptation we
have to do those experiments and I agree
and we're doing as much as we can
further complications are you
notification sure that along with
contingent
yes so the negative
one strategy for development inspector
that would depend on the integrated
aspect of practice
I think in the end it's the integrated
aspect of plant physiology because the
plan has to grow and produce enough
seeds to survive and that is the trade I
mean that will be selected on for sure
but but the environment I mean all these
accessions will have adapted to certain
environments and the way how you
actually are more fit in those different
environments will be very different and
just the question that I referred with
the root system architecture where we
then really looked at root system in the
soil that really related to
precipitation seasonality so so the
alleles that conferred either the
shallow or the deep one were were
basically correlated with the frequency
of rainfall in the areas where they came
from so it really depends I mean the a
good root system is only good for a
certain number of environments and and
not for all environments and at least
for those wild species I think
the hope our scientists could
in touch interaction between Zionism
how far yeah I would I would need to
look that up but but they basically what
they did for generating the fight of
genomics core they looked at auto logs
and many different genomes and looked at
either co-occurrence or Co absent like
you know either one or the other
but I I would need to look that up
yes but that also depends on the on the
on the condition
we really haven't looked for this but we
know it was very obvious in the mutants
that in two of the mutants of the
receptor kinases the the root hairs were
stunted which is also associated with
iron deficiency responses so but we
haven't looked in a systematic manner
because on those plate essays that we do
it's it's impossible to this two to get
the resolution for the root hairs
you could say so yes I mean like like
when there was like bigger growth
inhibition observed in the in the mutant
the routier seem to be more screwed up
but I I mean I know I mean I would
really need to look at it's it's very
anecdotal and that might be very biased
because the way how those things are
noticed are very biased typically
it does the factor that Connie
so my hypothesis is we haven't tested it
but I think it is there are a couple of
polymorphisms in the coding region that
don't lead to changes in the minor acid
sequence I think achieve this will
relate to RNA stability there's also
this study where they over expressed Pro
to with the 35s promoter under control
and iron conditions and even though the
35s shouldn't be affected by the iron
deficiency the expression level of pro 2
was still higher under iron deficiency
which would suggest a post
transcriptional regulation and and that
would be in line with the polymorphisms
that we observe in the in the transcript
but we haven't tested it but but then it
will be an RNA to an over factor somehow
and the great work there you know
thank you then I have one technical
question like Ethan
in our reductive
well under less than 400 micron
centaurum star the decision life and
most people got them so this is what the
electrification work
and the second question is in
agriculture most crowd
allocate problem to their background and
have an sort of Hoops would be a big
advantage for for for problems
so the function legged circus order is
very important like Thailand one
your main thing is the left that easy to
do but the function of the movie they're
very short very efficient absolutely I
mean I I fully agree I think the root
system architecture then at a later
stage will tell us a lot about you know
which soil layers can be explored how
efficient that they are for this I mean
we haven't really done this
systematically we would like to and I
think there are ways to look at later
root systems yeah so we would love to
think about this but and and we do as
far as we can but we really haven't
systematically studied later with
architecture and then the light
intensity I would need to look up how
many micro Einsteins are used what we
know is that we tests described mutants
for iron like the fro - mutant also the
IRT one that they basically whether we
can reproduce the effects that were that
were described for them and under our
light conditions we actually recaptured
relate the effects that were described
so yeah
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu